2013 ein wunderbares Jahr Corona war
noch eine Biermarke die Russen waren die
guten und Friedrich Merz saß Kekse
futternd in aufsichtsreiten alles toll
bis zum 6 Februar denn dann gründet dann
hoffen Opas mit zu viel Tagesfreizeit
eine Partei sie sind gegen Pleite
Griechen und hassen Energiesparlampen
warum auch immer und eine obskure
Sendung namens heute show schenkt der
Partei von Anfang an Sendezeit warum
aber ich habe davon nichts gewusst genau
das sagen die deutschen hinterher immer
doch schon kurz danach beginnen die
Säuberungen ein Vorsitzender nach dem
anderen verschwindet spurlos ach nee
warte mal bei denen kommt das erst noch
Strippenzieher und eigentlicher
Machthaber ist und bleibt einer von
diesen beiden Berns ein Mann der uns
viel mehr erzählt als wir wissen wollen
mein Vater ist jetzt eine Frau
glückwunsch das alles bei heute show
history höckes Helfer